[Music]
in a bad behavior news uh-oh submitted
by Sean from NOLA hi Sean North LA North
LA nearly Oh Nollan a Chinese student is
facing deportation from the Philippines
after throwing pudding at an officer
what probably shouldn't throw putting
out an officer yeah damn they're like
deported puddings not that good
you're lucky you didn't go to jail
pudding it's definitely not good then in
that case it's uh I think puddings okay
but I'm never gonna go out and go get
some pudding no proof is in the pudding
why would he do that so this is a female
oh yeah I liked how everyone thought
like I thought it was it yeah it all
must be male yeah so she's 23 she was
holding her cup of soy pudding when she
attempted to enter like the subway
station was it a tantrum
clearly I pictured her flogged in it
with like a spoon
oh oh slingshot style yeah I forgot to
put lotion on today that's when an
officer asked her to finish the food
before entering because liquids are not
permitted on the train and then she's
cuckoo [ __ ] threw it at the dudes
uniform
oh damn sure these photos went viral
yeah what's her deal she could just like
finish it it looks like baby vomit she
tossed it oh that's a lot of pudding
yeah we should have like a whole
homemade Cup I hope these goes viral
that's what you saying I hope these
caused by her use so the world can see
what kind of [ __ ] you are
she's a first-year fashion students well
if you know I kind of wish that I'm some
good old-fashioned American police
brutality when it went down and you want
to just hopped over the fence just
tackle this let me board is asking for
it seem right in the head though I know
so she's hoarding soy pudding yeah
[ __ ] idiot kid get some taste buds I
agree that's where she first did you see
her out I know was it even chocolate
yeah she's
can we go back and see that she's been
living in the Philippines for six years
oh let me see the rest yeah you know
what the Fashion Police
should just deport her so yeah they're
talking about deporting just off of her
fashion alone like not even with the
pudding oh yeah
what is that share the [ __ ] police
station t she's rolling her eyes in her
mug shot
how does she change in one [ __ ] photo
look different times yeah what are those
two different girls no it's the same
girl but her hairstyle is to say rain I
know she's a fashionista she searches
maybe she gets in trouble alive because
she had to go back to because of this
whole thing you got babes
she got like temporary bail or whatever
so then guess so she was saying that she
was in a really bad mood she was not
able to control her emotions she admits
that she made a mistake and that she's
very regretful that's what her lawyer
Twitter's safe if it's possible to have
another chance because she loves the
Philippines and she loves the people
there she just wants to she's 23
oh she's staying in the Philippines yeah
go to school Oh where's your China Oh at
23 I don't think you're no longer
allowed to have like tantrums like that
yeah that's not your 12in someone for
your like your mom I'm in a bad man you
if I can throw some mashed potatoes
maybe it was some excuse keep that in
the house to your boyfriend you get the
[ __ ] over it yeah and you're in another
country your goddamn grown woman sorry I
overreacted
I think Tiger was 12 and he threw food
at mammoth rose Astor a window like a
first three window or a second-story I
probably put them over my shoulder and
go to the highest story as possible but
is like people on the bottom could get
hurt no one cross because I'm gonna
throw my key for the window ooh
fly babies instead of timber things like
I'm crazy ass girl man
I don't know if I could throw things out
an officer that might be and don't
[ __ ] kill me here but I feel like
that's like a China thing though like
how many stories have we reported where
the girl is like verbally abused
yeah and having tantrums and like moms
well they're definitely not scared of
law enforcement the way we are they're
not no they're not the good
old-fashioned American police brutality
I was scared of cops so before any of
that before it was aware of it like at
14 15 16 years old I wasn't that aware
of like the cop situation I've never
been handled by a cop not as much as you
I'm sure and also but even on one time
that we got pulled over it's good all
fashion remember when we got pulled over
I was heck ascared there but I got
pulled over at 16 I had my license for
like dream I could all I've never had a
good old-fashioned lovin but I got
pulled over like 16 yeah and I was
scared shitless I was scared shitless
and I'd never heard of anyone getting
beaten up by cause it's like oh they're
gonna tell on me so you know that
there's I'm gonna go to jail yeah well I
didn't want to tell my parents I did
want to get a ticket I don't want to get
trouble I used to get scared what my
teacher yelled at me I all gonna get
[ __ ] up yeah but you guys grew up in
like LA it's a little different I never
thought of it that way like they were
gonna beat my ass I saw oh my god it's
gonna be so good and I automatically I
think because of how my parents raised
me I had like automatic respect like I
just called him sir but I would call my
teacher sir I'd call if I would've met
your dad I would call him Sir like maybe
I've witnessed the good old-fashioned
strong army hence I was like because
I've seen fights break down at school
yeah when the cops come they're just
like grabbing these little two little
pencil necks and it's [ __ ] loud just
saw I've just seen how they are but then
that made you what respectful yeah what
I'm saying is I didn't see that and I
was still predictable but fearful but in
a different way but like we I think we
had different experience like growing up
I was still kind of fearful but I was
just respectful yeah different fears
maybe I was this guy was gonna be a punk
you were in Taiwan and we would see like
a civilian yelling back I am [ __ ]
speed you [ __ ] idiot yeah you did
speed I caught you
he goes no you're [ __ ] blind yeah
yell back and forth all day that is
crazy
so I was like old [ __ ] that's scary but
yeah like you said China or Joe said
China might might not know I've seen the
same thing like don't just be arguing
with cops they'll go wow the Filipino
word cop didn't do nothing
I know but he just kind of stood there
you look real grumpy we just did put it
on him it looked like she didn't really
do it you probably like down and out he
was just like having a bad
he's like yeah so I put yes for a guy I
know he looks like goddamnit
look at his eyes dude he looks like I'm
going to hop over here right now [ __ ]
you up that's all it's dead someone's
got some all I want to do is get the
paycheck so just get her ass beat by
whoever his family isn't even my sister
did that to someone one time um my
sisters used to work at a video store
remember those the block was like a
block what was like a mom-and-pop yeah
and that was like the cool job back in
her cuz she grew up in the 80s so that
was like the cool [ __ ] so she worked at
a video store she didn't drive at the
time my mom drove her to her job and
then um as my mom's like she stops my
sister gets out and a car had already
pulled out so um this new car comes in
and starts honking at my mom but then
parts right and then this girl comes out
it's based off what my mom and my sister
both having comes out and in the girl
thought that my mom was trying to steal
her parking space she's like what the
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] and my mom's like
in the car and her windows like this
much down and she immediately grabs my
mom's hair yeah she reached through yeah
and then I guess someone told my sister
who was at work like hey like your mom
it's getting in a fight right now my
sister run out she just liked a [ __ ]
huh she punked a [ __ ] yeah and like
she's just got her she started like
punching her and that this girl had like
braces and she was just like bleeding
everywhere and her good old-fashioned
American brutality there we go and then
her boyfriend like the girl's boyfriend
like came in and stopped it she's like
dude I'm so sorry like I don't like like
like broke it up and was that girl
Chinese too I don't know maybe Mexican
oh yeah those Chinese preservatives
yeah she she put her hands on your mom
dude I even saw one of my sister's
ex-boyfriend and I saw this they got in
a fight like he fought my dad what you
gonna fistfight with
ghetto huh yeah so I can't even imagine
your death fistfight he's such a cool
chill gun no dude he's like a silent
killer like he doesn't he doesn't give
you any warning he's just like let's go
[ __ ]
the guy like they had broken up the guy
kept coming over my old old high school
senior you're still sprung on your
sister yeah he was like dude go home
like leave my daughter
oh she doesn't anything to do with you
and then um I guess like he just didn't
want to go and then my like he pushed my
dad and my dad just like got on top of
him and he kicked his ass and he just
stayed on like he just sat on I'm like
dude like calm the [ __ ] down
well he was like a groan like he was a
kid right he was a high school kid or
something yeah yeah yeah so my dad
didn't want to like kick his ass but he
like definitely mean up chill I know I
just I just remembered that American
kids are big though you know I mean like
if if I have some kids that date Samoans
I don't know if I could [ __ ] do that
what about how you protect your daughter
I'm gonna learn how to kick balls really
good I'm gonna try to kill kids cuz
they're high school kids I'm not gonna
pull a gun on them scare intimidation
yeah my dad always had a sawed-off
shotgun like what does I mean big cut
the stalk off stalk off of it so it's
just way smaller kind of barrel is short
this is my more common way did your dad
you still like Hank like do that [ __ ]
coming up with two of them I goddamn
terminator he would just make like a
funny little joke like shotgun so you
guys have fun he's like yo 77 yeah yeah
revolvers well he must be like me thanks
I didn't get none of that well I'm older
I got warmness I'm older now he doesn't
need to protect my old ass
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]